my name is Mustafa abubakar gradual
I'm 31 years old
I'm the managing director and co-founder
of Phoenix Renewables
I am a Borno State origin
it's a ride from my childhood age I
always love to see that I solve problems
that people around me are facing
Vehicles powered by petroleum or let me
say petroleum products are causing so
much harm to our environment because
they emit so much carbon causes a lot of
diseases most especially respiratory
diseases which are causing so much
damage to even unborn babies nowadays so
we try as much as possible to see how we
could come up with uh
materials that are sustainable and that
they can be sourced locally here
our vehicles they have been powered by
electric motors this electric motors are
now powered by batteries
we designed these vehicles with multiple
charging sources it can charge using the
solar panels which can can be deployed
at strategic locations or you can even
charge it using your 13 amp socket
that's just this plug at home you can
just plug to it and it will charge it's
not very easy for startups like us
we don't have much people who are key
into the kind of vision we have
my vision is one day the America and the
Europe to come and buy our vehicles